Jeff joins us now let me give the full
introduction Wednesday night baseball
this week at 8:00 Eastern
Jeff will appear on Wednesday night
baseball part of baseball tonight the
road show at Fenway Park coming up this
weekend it'll be the Red Sox and the
Yankees got the trade deadline coming up
by the way Jeff we talked about this
before good morning the White Sox only
needed three days to install this
protective netting here so nobody can
use that excuse I released that excuse
is falling on deaf ears that these teams
can't put it in what is the holdup with
some of these other teams that haven't
put in the protective netting there's no
good excuse down at all there's no good
excuse there's no good reason there's
nothing rationale there's no good logic
there is nothing that is preventing
these teams from doing that and it is
shameful that Major League Baseball has
not stepped in and said this is
something that's important to us and
we're mandating it and the fact that
injuries keep that oh yeah I'm still
here I kind of call beeping in but I'm
gonna hit the good old decline button
sorry buddy
could be the Commissioner could be the
Commissioner he knows how I feel about
this and uh I just I've said it to
multiple times and I just I think it's I
think it's wrong I just think it is a
moral failure on baseball's part to not
prioritize this and and make it
important if nothing else Stan just to
say to fans we care yeah we hear you
well the White Sox Nationals Pirates
Royals Orioles Dodgers Rangers have done
this nothing yet from the other 23 teams
a couple of things
you got the trade deadline only one
deadline this year biggest name who will
be moved is who oh boy I don't want to
say that Mike Minor is definitely going
to be the biggest I just think he's the
biggest who's guaranteed to be moves at
this point and when you're saying Mike
Minor is the biggest name that might
move so that shows you this has the
capacity to be a very boring trade dead
no okay well Madison Bumgarner
you know he was there for the taking it
felt like and then now the Giants are
playing well you don't think I would
have said Madison Bumgarner
unequivocally two weeks ago then the
Giants decided to become the best team
in baseball and and it's stunning to see
their turnaround considering just how
bad they were for the first three months
of the season I mean they were bad teeth
they were they were on the list of clear
obvious guaranteed sellers and you know
for Hans ID in his first year on the job
has done a really good job of taking
this team on the fly and turning it into
something and he said you know his
entire career has been with the Oakland
A's and McAndrew Freedmen's Dodgers two
teams that have shown a great facility
to do that to find assets that have been
either undervalued underappreciated in
many cases unwanted and turn them into
tangible major-league players and that's
what they've generated I mean Mike what
Mike Ostrovsky is doing is is incredible
and mica shrimp ski has been really an
organizational player for for the
majority of his career and now he's
hitting in the middle of the lineup and
you know going off with walk-offs
like it's it's just a it's a sign that
the Giants are not to be taken lightly
and yet they don't want to get wrapped
up in this idea that just because
they're winning now just because the
National League is as wide open as it is
that they shouldn't consider selling
because they are you know they have a
lot of desirable guys whether it's
Bumgarner or Will Smith Tony Watson Sam
Dyson who could help contending teams
they just have trouble looking at
themselves right now and saying we're
not one of those contending teams
talking to Jeff Passan ESPN baseball
insider what was your biggest takeaway
from the Hall of Fame weekend brandy
Halladay speech was incredible like the
yeah our courage is the right word
fortitude is probably better and and the
fortitude to get up there after the the
greatest tragedy anyone can possibly
imagine and speak so eloquently and and
really encapsulating them
what her husband was I mean let's
remember Roy Halladay's career this is a
guy who was a first-round pick and when
he got to the major leagues he
absolutely lost it absolutely lost it
and had to go all the way back down to
able to figure out who he was in what he
was going to be and you know everybody
at at some point in their life reaches
that precipice and they have to say to
themselves I'm going to make it over and
I'm going to be a better person because
of it or I'm going to fold and Roy
Halladay's ability his mental fortitude
was always the greatest strength that he
had even more than the ability to throw
a baseball 60 feet and six inches over a
plate and and it serves him well and you
know I saw some Twitter trolls out there
saying the only reason or how it is in
the Hall of Fame is because he died know
Roy Halladay was going to be a Hall of
Famer whether he was not with us or was
and to see Brandi Halladay take that
moment and and really imbue it with
everything that he meant to people was
special I asked this question yesterday
would you rather have greg madduxês
career or Mariano Rivera's career that's
a great question
thank you Jeff you're welcome Dan may
you you're a pro you could pass that on
to greeny on get up and let him or
Timothy I here's the thing I love
everything that Mariano Rivera did his
postseason numbers are incredible here
comes the bunted here coming yeah I
asked you though Greg Maddux was was the
god of pitching when I was growing up I
used to come home and get off the bus
and run to my house and flick TBS on
when Maddux are starting just to watch
him carve up hitters with like a 90 mile
per hour fastball that would run and
would sink and that would cut and that
would do all of these untoward unseemly
things that I did not think human beings
could do manipulating baseballs and
Maddux is the right answer
yeah the fact that he lived at ninety
and was good as he was the fact that he
had the back-to-back one five four and
one six three er a seasons when when
hitting I'm not going to say was at its
peak but was really good god that guy
was incredible and still is and and Greg
Maddux is one of like the dirtiest
grossest filthiest human beings alive
and in Mariano like I would I would love
to have a mind as dirty as greg madduxês
I leave you with this the Hall of Fame
future balloting voting is what we got
jeeps coming it's Jeets 100 percenter no
I think I think there's gonna be so many
out there who is anti cheats just to be
at IG okay mean should be I think my
view on the Hall of Fame is its binary
either and say yes or to know and there
are some guys out there I think if
you're in you should be in a hundred
percent but yeah that's not the case the
interesting part of Dan is if you look
at next year Derek Jeter's the only
clear guy who's in if you look at the
year after there is nobody who's gonna
be the first time on the ballot who's
going to get in I wonder if that paves
the way for Curt Schilling you know for
Larry Walker this year and most
important for Barry Bonds and Roger
Clemens well do you think that they get
in in two years I think they should I
think there's probably though a large
enough resistance block to them I mean
all you need is is you know one out of
every four voters plus one and neither
of them gets in and I think the way that
the electorate is currently constituted
they're gonna have a difficult time
getting in and they're gonna end up you
know in the mid to high 60s
Larry Walker's last year on the ballot
you know if he had two more years if he
was if he was there with Schilling Larry
Walker might get in and I hope Schilling
gets in I look me too I don't agree with
his politics but I agree and with with
the consensus that when you won a game
in a big game you want Schilling on the
mound and you know I put put the other
stuff to the Sasha Kurt Kurt Kurt
Schilling dan is a Hall of Fame pitcher
it like simple as that and I you know
when I vote I do not vote anymore I gave
up my ballot because I disagree with the
Hall of Fame's politics and the way that
they've handled performance-enhancing
drugs I just think that they've hidden
behind their actual feelings and I wish
that they would come out as a museum and
say this is how we feel about it even if
it is at the critical I'd like to know
but I always voted for Curt Schilling
because I think Curt Schilling's
performance on the field which to me is
what the Hall of Fame is supposed to be
there to promote why is he not in the
Hall of Fame finish that sentence Curt
Schilling's not in the Hall of Fame
because people think he's a turd but
that's politics it is politics and it's
wrong but that's that's the reality Dan
I I wish that were not the case and I
hope that people come to their come to
their senses and see that this is a guy
who did historically good things in both
the regular season and the postseason
was a part of championship ball clubs
pitched in big games was at the
forefront of the strikeout revolution
like he he was a guy who absolutely on
the merits of what he did on the
baseball field deserves to be in Jeff
have fun at Fenway
coming up baseball tonight the road show
at Fenway this Sunday at 8:00 Eastern
Red Sox and the Yankees always great to
talk to you Jeff Jeff Passan from the
mothership for more Dan Patrick show
tune in the audience channel 239 on
DirecTV streamed for free on be our live
or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]